the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
once again i am very excited to be able
to bring you this new information
as i have said before i love when we
find out any information that has been
kept behind the scenes for many years
finally we have some answers about why
lady stoneheart was left out of the show
dan and dave actually gave three reasons
why they ultimately decided not to
include her
thanks to james hibbard over at
entertainment weekly he has released
some information from his upcoming book
fire cannot kill a dragon now unless you
have been living under a rock
most of you should know who lady
stoneheart is but for those of you that
might not know
let me give you a brief summary of who
the character is and how she came to be
as you all know lady catelyn stark was
killed during the red wedding but what
we did not see in the show is what
happened to her
after this shortly after lady catelyn
died
her body was thrown into the river where
it would stay for the next three days
well on that third day of her body being
in the river arya's direwolf nymeria
dragged her body out of that river
now i'm sure you all can imagine what
lady catelyn must have looked like
in that moment unfortunately right
before lady catelyn died
she more or less lost her mind after
witnessing the death of her son
rob stark you see moments before she was
killed
catelyn actually dug her own nails into
her face
leaving these horrific scratch marks all
over then
of course her throat was cut open so
when nymeria found her after she had
been floating in the water for three
days
she was almost unrecognizable shortly
after nymeria brings her body to the
shore
the brotherhood without banners arrive
on the scene this is when beric
dondarrion gives her the kiss of life
obviously barrick dies because his life
force goes into her
but lady catelyn is resurrected as lady
stoneheart
she is no longer the same woman we once
knew
now she is out for vengeance on anyone
she believes was involved with the red
wedding
now the brotherhood without banners
follow her as she gets her revenge on
houses frey
lannister and bolton and it doesn't take
long before they come across their first
victim from house frey
lady stoneheart hasn't had very many
scenes in the book since she was brought
back
but whenever she does show up those
moments end up becoming some of my
favorite scenes to read
lady stoneheart is fascinating now if
you have not read the books
then you might want to check out my
video on the character i actually made a
video a few years ago where i go
over her storyline in the books i will
add the link to that video down below
if you would like to check it out
alright now i think i have done enough
setup so let me show you what dan and
dave said about why they left her out of
the show
so the article at entertainmentweekly
says so
there are three reasons the first reason
remains a bit
vague because it involves what martin
has secretly planned for lady stoneheart
and his storylines versus the show story
lines
one of the reasons we did not want to
include her had to do with things coming
up in george's books that we don't want
to spoil by discussing them
benioff says now maybe it's just me but
i think this is a dumb reason to keep
her out of the show
considering everything else they spoiled
over the years
now obviously i don't know exactly how
the books will end but george rr martin
has more or less confirmed that bran
stark will be the king by the end of his
story
so dan and dave are willing to reveal
something that significant
but not lady stoneheart's storyline they
showed us how all the main characters
die
although they could be different in the
books but for some reason they don't
want to show us some of the things lady
stoneheart might do
not only that but they could have
brought her back without spoiling
anything from george's books
they could have just given her character
a different ending like they have done
with so many others
they also revealed one of the biggest
secrets in the story
which was who is jon snow's real mother
and father
now maybe i'm just being selfish for
wanting to see lady stoneheart so bad
but they already revealed so much anyway
so why not just
include her too it would have made the
show even better
now let me show you the second reason
they gave the second reason was that
even when writing season 3
the duo knew they were going to do a
major death and resurrection across
seasons 5 and 6.
and they wanted to make sure that stayed
shocking and suspenseful
we knew we had jon snow's resurrection
coming up benioff says too many
resurrections start to diminish the
impact a character is dying
you know what i actually won't argue
with that because i do kind of agree
with it to some extent
now i would still rather have lady
stoneheart than not having her at all
but if you want to argue this reasoning
then feel free to sound off down in the
comments section of the video
you know i always love to hear what you
have to say now i want to show you their
third reason for not including lady
stoneheart because i do have something
to say about this
their third reason was that the red
wedding was one of the show's most
powerful moments
a dramatic home run as executed by
director david nutter
and the show's cast had exactly the
impact they had long hoped for
the share runners felt that bringing
back a former catelyn stark
might weaken what was accomplished by
the scene in that a silent
undead version of catelyn seemed beneath
the dignity of actress michelle fairley
who was already supernaturally haunting
as a doomed human in her final minutes
catelyn's last moment was so fantastic
and michelle was such a great actress
to bring her back as a zombie who
doesn't speak felt like diminishing
returns
benioff says well let me tell you
something david and dan
how about bringing both of you back to
write the final season
felt like diminishing returns how about
that
so basically what they're saying is they
were afraid that bringing lady
stoneheart
back would take away from her amazing
scene during the red wedding
they felt like this would retroactively
hurt the show but guess what
the final season they gave us
retroactively hurt the entire series
not just one scene like the red wedding
they thought this would hurt the
integrity of one episode
yet they somehow did not see how every
other decision they made
hurt the entire show they really are
dumb and dumber
well lady catelyn does come back in the
books and it doesn't affect
her final moments during the red wedding
whatsoever at least it doesn't affect it
to me
but hey who knows maybe it would for
someone else
i think i do speak for most of us though
when i say we would have liked for her
to be included in the show
do you know who else wanted lady
stoneheart on the show george rr martin
the creator of the story wanted her in
the show even if it spoiled his own
books
in fact george said lady stoneheart has
a role in the books
whether it's sufficient or interesting
enough i think it is or i would not have
brought her back
one of the things i wanted to show with
her is that the death she suffers
changes you in one of his interviews
with esquire china
george r martin once said in the winds
of winter
i still continue to write her she is an
important character in the set of books
keeping her character is the change i
most wish i could make in the show
let me read that last line again just in
case you missed it
george r martin said keeping her
character is the change i most wish i
could make in the show
now actually think about that think
about all the changes that were made in
the show
out of all those changes george r
martin's number one wish was that they
would have included lady stoneheart
if he doesn't care about spoiling his
own character's storyline
then why should dan and dave if this
doesn't tell you that lady stoneheart is
a significant character then i don't
know what will
don't hold back folks let me hear what
you have to say about this revelation
i will see you down in the comments
section i want to thank everyone for
watching the video
thank all of you for continuing to
support the channel i hope everyone has
a great
day i will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
so
you